[Music]
oscars are coming up on sunday oh boy
and i know andy here has oscar fever
yeah yeah i call it hollywood christmas
what i don't know i'm just trying things
there are nine nominees for best picture
and uh here's the problem a lot of
people have not seen all the movies i
bet a bunch of you haven't seen all the
movies and you're worried because you're
gonna go to an oscar party people are
gonna be talking about the films and
you're not gonna be able to join in the
fun right well don't you worry andy and
i we're here to help okay check this out
each night we're gonna perform a pivotal
scene from one of the nominated films so
this weekend when you're watching with
friends you can sort of join in and
based on what we've acted out you can
talk about the movie make your pool
picks exactly pal
last night we did the artist okay we
acted it out for people and i think that
was a huge help i'm sure they've all
heard about it yeah okay well tonight
we've chosen the help all right it takes
place during the civil rights era it
involves the struggle of a young white
woman to expose her town's racism
towards the local african-american
maids
now to set up the scene i'm going to be
playing hilly who's a white woman who's
trying to introduce legislation
requiring all maids to have separate
bathrooms yeah
and i'll be playing skeeter the young
and pretty white girl
who's fighting for equality there we go
let me get that on there
you got it
oh
this is not that different from my real
hair
we've also enlisted the help of one of
our writers dion cole to play the part
of abilene
the maid with a heart of gold
[Music]
we now present you a scene from the help
and
begin
skeeter
i just think maids should use their own
bathrooms separate but equal that's what
the governor says
well i don't understand why we can't all
use the same facilities we're all god's
creatures
abe lane
sugar you enjoy your new bathroom over
to elizabeth
do we really got to do this
all right all right just okay
listen up you stupid [ __ ] uh
anywhere you put your white racist
cracks i can also put my black ass not
that i want to
cause you probably both got butt
chlamydia
[Applause]
dion has clearly improvised his own
lines
this is [ __ ] man i'm out here peace
you